初めての字幕チャレンジ！
こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーです
お待たせしました
2018年
お菓子・ジュースを禁止した年（つらい）
ラーメンを禁止した年（つらい）
そして2018年！
僕は、僕は何を禁止すればいいのか
というわけで動画のコメントで
みなさんに何を禁止したらいいかの
ポン
コメントを募ったんですけども
その結果が集まりましたので
えーみなさんに紹介していこうと
思います
結構ですね 被ってました！
中にはすごいそのコメントに
グッドが多かったやつとかあったんで
ちょっとコメントの中で
目立ったものとか
「おっ（ 　＾ω＾ ）」と思ったやつを
ちょっとまずは紹介していこう
と思います
何を禁止するかは
（もやしのガン見）
それからだぁ！
ぴゅんぴゅぴゅん
あーー これですね
これめちゃくちゃ多かったですね
お弁当とか買い食いの禁止、自炊をする
めちゃくちゃ多いし
僕もしたいところではあるんですけどもォ！
なぜ弁当とか買い食いするかっていうと
あの…
時間がない
自炊する時間がね
確保できないと思うんで
これは無理です！
つぎ！！
無理！ つぎぃ！！
要するにネットショッピング禁止
ってことですよね
これねぇ いいと思うんですけど（指さし）
あのー 僕の本性知ってますか？
引きこもりなんですよ（知ってたｂｙ字幕製作者）
できれば家から出たくなあい！
無理ぃ！つぎぃ！
多いな おい！
いやこれ すごい多かったです
コンビニ禁止っていうのは
すごい多かったんですけども
コンビニを禁止することによって
何が起きるかと言いますと
僕たぶん死にます（ドヤァ）
ライフラインが断たれてしまうので
無理！つぎぃ！
関係ねぇわ！
ありがと
来年の動画 多分
こんなんなってますからね
無理無理無理無理無理！
髪の毛を切らないことによるメリットが
ちょっと…
…分からん
バカ野郎！バカ野郎か！
洋服禁止ってことは新幹線乗るときも
移動中とかも全部 裸ってことですよね？
【逮捕（ ＾ω＾ ）】
無理
いや夏場とかけっこう厳しい
と思うんですけども
正直 余裕なんですよ
あの僕 2年前お菓子とジュース
1年禁止しましたからね
ピンポイントでアイスクリームとか言われても
すごいとてもクソ余裕なんで
もうちょっとね
今までよりハードルを上げたいな
って思ってる自分がいます
ドМかもしれません
つぎぃ！
いろんな面で時間の短縮が
めちゃくちゃできてるんで
自炊する時間がない中
コンビニ禁止は多分ほんとに
動画の投稿頻度が週1ぐらいに
減るんじゃねえかぐらいの（それでもはじめが元気になるなら良いよ）
ちょっと不安があるんで
あんまりおすすめではないです
（コメント欄での誹謗中傷は相手を傷つけます、コメ欄は仲良くしましょう）
死なねえよ
みんなのためになぁ！
賛成です！
結構ありだと思います
パン禁止 結構ありだと
思ったんですけども
なんかでも難しいよね パン…
どこまでがパンの線引きかが
ちょっと難しいところだったんで
なんか無理
あっ…
【考えるもやし】
無理ぃ！
やめろぉ！オレの日常を操る
素敵な時間を奪わないでくれぇ！
許してぇ…
いや これもですね
余裕ですよ？
こういうのもですね
お菓子とジュースを禁止した
僕からするともう朝飯前…
なんで下なの！？
はい というわけでみなさん
たくさんのコメント
ありがとうございました
いろんなコメントがある中で
やっぱり多かったのがですね
牛丼禁止がすごい多かったです
甘いな
甘い！
お菓子・ジュースを禁止し
ラーメンを禁止し
つぎは牛丼！
甘くないか？
ラーメンが戻ってきた僕にとって
牛丼禁止は結構 余裕なんですよ
たぶん 分かんないですけど
正直厳しいかもしれませんが
僕の中では 多分余裕だと思っています
てか余裕です！
うん…
いいんだよ…
これでいいんだよ…
【はじめの咆哮】
はい というわけで 今年禁止するものは…
肉！
でございます
なぜこのチョイスに至ったか
3つほど理由があります
えーっと まず…
なんだろうなあ
なんだろうなっておかしいな
牛丼禁止にするのが妥当だと
思ったんですけども
それだと…
あのーー
ありそうじゃないすか
何かこう一捻り加えて
もっと上にいけないかと思ったところ
牛丼を禁止するのではなく
もうそれならいっそのこと
肉全部やめちゃえばいいんじゃね
っていう発想に至ったので
今回 肉を禁止させていただきます
1年間です
うぅ…
いけるかなぁ？
意外といけると思うんですよ！
あと僕自体 そんなに肉が好きなタイプ
じゃないんで
いや好きですけど
今年もまだ焼肉に行ってないし
牛丼もね 多分食ってないかな？
えっと お肉と言いつつも
えっと豚肉、鶏肉…
えー 牛肉あたりを禁止します
いや 僕ちょっと
いろいろ調べたんですけども
お肉を食べないメリットって
結構あるみたいで
なんか肉ってなんか腸に残ったりして
悪玉菌を増やす原因になると
言われているみたいでございます
なんでなんかお肉食べないと
体質がいい意味で変わったりする
みたいです
あと肉を食べないと
イライラや怒りっぽい性格が
穏やかになると言われています
おぉー！これは全然ね
あのね やる価値あると思うんすよ
肉を食うとなんか野生臭くなるみたいな
ことを聞いたことあるんで
いいことだらけじゃん！
いやーなんかお肉を食べないことって
結構いいことが
いろいろあるみたいなんで
ちょっと1年間
頑張ってみようと思います！
え、じゃあ オレやばいじゃん！
焼肉も行けないってことでしょ
牛丼も禁止、唐揚げ禁止
いや…
やれ はじめ…！
やるしかねえ！
やります！！
完全その菜食主義者になる
っていう訳でもないので
普通に卵とかも食べるし
魚とかは食べようと思ってるんで
このがっつりとしたお肉だけは
NOということにしたいと思います
あの すごいコメント欄でも
「お肉禁止」っていうのが多かったんで
全然 僕は
やれると思います
今回はきれいに1年というより
1月1日まで！
禁止します
約1年ですね
お肉を1年間 食べなかったら
どういう風に体とか なんか性格とか
変化するのかちょっと見ていこう
と思います
いや焼肉禁止はでかいな…
まあ いいや、焼肉屋に行っても
なんか野菜とか食べてればいい
ってことでしょ
やってやんよー！
うわあぁー
いただきまーす
ほんとに最後なのね
【悲しげな音楽】
（ナレーター風に：これが2018年）
（はじめしゃちょーが食べた）
（最後のお肉であった）
（うっ…）
（うぅ…）
【はじめの唸り声】
（焼肉食べたいよぉ）
（うぅぅぅぅぅuuuuuuuu
【♪∼  ED (悲しげな音楽ver.)】がんばれはじめ
字幕初チャレンジどうでしたか？まだまだ至らない点があるのでご指導ご鞭撻よろしくおねがいします、じゃあな！